- All right, I love searching the internet
for the best stories that
might make you smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
As we've mentioned, today is
International Day of the Girl,
which supports opportunities
for women and girls everywhere,
including sports.
Often, women's sports
take a backseat to men's,
but not at a new sports
ball in Portland, Oregon.
No ma'am.
The bar primarily plays
women's sports on their TVs.
Even better is the name of the bar.
You ready?
It's called Sports Bra,
which is, which is great.
(applause)
It's already, you wanna go.
Here to talk about it is Jenny,
the owner of The Sports Bra,
watching on FOX 12 Oregon at 3.
What's up, Jenny?
(cheering)
(applause)
- Hi, Kelly.
Thanks for having me.
- Oh my God, thank you
for the name of your bar.
So, where did you get the idea for this?
- So, basically a bunch
of my friends and I,
we love playing sports
and after we would go play basketball,
we'd always wanna go watch
sports at a bar or something.
And so, there was one time in 2018,
a bunch of friends of mine and I
went to go see a women's Final Four game.
And we went into this sports
bar and there's 30 TVs;
none of 'em have the game on.
And so we sit down, we ask
them to change the channel,
which they did,
and it's kind of in the
corner of this restaurant
and we watch this incredible game,
but without the sound on.
And it was then that I realized
that if I ever wanted to
watch a women's sports
game in its full glory,
I'd have to open my own place.
And so that's what I did.
In 2021, we opened The Sports
Bra here in Portland, Oregon
and since then we've
had incredible crowds.
For Serena's last match, we
had just an incredible crowd.
We had the WNBA finals here
and saw a ton of people.
The Portland Thorns get
a bunch of attention here
and it's just been great
having a space dedicated
to women's sports.
- That's incredible.
And you're not just supporting
women through sports.
What else are you doing?
- That's correct.
Basically, we're trying to support women
on and off the field.
You know, the name The Sports Bra,
our motto is, "We support women."
And it's funny and it's
also what we try to do here.
We try to support our
local small businesses
that are women-owned and operated.
For example, Freeland Spirits does a lot
of our signature cocktails.
All the beef that we serve
here is from Carman Ranch;
it is a female rancher in Oregon.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- [Jenny] And then we have
21 taps and everything
on the taps is either owned,
operated, or made by women.
- I love--
- Even some of the furniture
in the restaurant is made
by girls who are young
and being trained to go into carpentry.
- That is so cool.
Like way to support your fellow women.
That's so cool.
Thank you so much, Jenny.
I'm liking your post about
The Sports Bra right now
that supports all of us.
(applause)
That's not all, though.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
they want to honor businesses
like The Sports Bra,
so they're gonna be writing you a check
for $1,000 just 'cause you're cool.
(clapping)
(cheering)
- Oh my God, cool.
Thank you so much.
- No, thank you so much, Jenny.
Have a blessed night.
Thank you to all of our guests this hour.
Sam Smith, Jacob Anderson,
Kylie, Laila, and Ms. La Pierre.
Y'all have a great day and if it's not,
try and change it.